hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so let's get into
this video we're gonna be talking about
how to work with parallelograms
rectangles ramas and squares and I just
want to show you how they're related to
each other to help you in your geometry
class so let's go ahead and take a look
at this hierarchy over here so what we
have here at the uppermost you know
trunk here of the tree is polygons
okay so polygons could be triangles
those have three sides quadrilaterals
four-sided figures Pentagon's five sided
figures hexagons and so on but what
we're doing is we're focusing on the
quadrilaterals here so the four-sided
figures okay if you take that down one
more level quadrilaterals can be
subdivided into kites parallelograms and
trapezoids okay now let's see if we can
kind of talk about the distinctions here
so a kite actually looks something like
this okay and what's interesting about a
kite is it has two pairs of consecutive
sides meaning the sides that are next to
each other
congruent so these two sides are
congruent these two sides are congruent
but these are not congruent now what's
interesting about a kite is that there's
no pairs of opposite sides parallel okay
so these are not parallel and these are
not parallel when we go to a
parallelogram a parallelogram looks
something like this okay and a
parallelogram actually has two pairs of
opposite sides parallel so these are
parallel and these are parallel whereas
a trapezoid only has one pair of
opposite sides parallel so you can see
these are parallel if they kept going
they wouldn't cross but these two sides
if they kept going they would intersect
so if you're thinking about you know how
do i distinguish between these different
quadrilaterals think about do they have
any pairs of opposite sides parallel do
they have to do they have one do they
have none so continuing on or focusing
on parallelogram so where you have two
pairs of opposite sides parallel and
then you can subdivide down from there
you can subdivide down to
rectangles and rhombuses around by
however you want to say it and then
squares but let's start with
parallelograms here so parallelograms
let's go through the different
properties of parallelograms so a
parallelogram looks something like this
okay so you want to memorize these
different properties but by
understanding how all the figures are
related to each other you can reduce
down you know the number of things that
you have to remember for each shape and
I'll show you what I mean so
parallelogram we know that these
opposite sides are parallel okay like
that so that's what the arrows represent
we know that the opposite sides are
congruent so these are the same length
these are the same length
we know that the opposite angles are
congruent okay so the angles that are
across from each other are equal we know
that the consecutive angles meaning the
angles that are next to each other
those are supplementary they add up to
180 degrees and we know that the
diagonals okay if they bisect each other
so they cut each other in half so I'm
just gonna put three marks here and I'll
put four marks over here okay so they're
cutting each other in half so those are
the properties of parallelograms so then
when you go down two rectangles a
rectangle it is a parallelogram it is a
quadrilateral is a polygon so it has all
the properties of the ones above it on
the tree here okay but in addition to
the properties above it it has
additional ones and for a rectangle okay
rectangle basically looks like this it
is a parallelogram it has all the
properties we mentioned here plus it has
four right angles okay for 90 degree
angles represented by these boxes right
also what a rectangle does is it has
congruent diagonals so this diagonal is
going to be the same length as that
diagonal because the diagonals bisect
each other in a parallelogram this piece
this piece this piece in this piece are
all going to be congruent
okay started with me so far okay so now
we're going to talk about rhombi or
rhombuses however you want to say it
rhombi for plural right a rhombus is a
parallelogram it is a quadrilateral is a
polygon but in
to all the properties above a rhombus
kind of looks like a diamond shape and
has four congruent sides okay so all
four sides are congruent and what's
interesting here is that the diagonals
are perpendicular to one another they
form right angles 90-degree angles and
one more thing the diagonals are going
to bisect or cut in half the opposite
angles so they're actually going to cut
those angles and exactly in half okay so
what you want to do is you want to think
about okay rhombus is a parallelogram so
it has all the properties you know the
opposite sides are going to be congruent
the opposite sides are going to be
parallel the opposite angles are
congruent and so on but in addition it
has four congruent sides okay and the
diagonals are perpendicular okay and the
diagonals bisect are cut in half the
opposite angles if we go down to square
a-square you can see is actually a
combination of a rectangle and a rhombus
some teachers joke that it's a round
tangle okay so they kind of like combine
the names but it's really okay a square
is a combination of a rectangle and
Aramis and it'll have all the properties
of the ones above it here on this chart
not like a kite in a trapezoid but just
down this main trunk right here so if
you look at a square it pretty much has
everything that you could possibly think
of okay it has the four right angles
like a rectangle it has the four
congruent sides like a rhombus and then
all the other properties like you know
that we talked about above so one last
tip in this video is that sometimes
you're looking at a figure and you might
forget you say hmm in a rectangle to do
the diagonals in a rectangle do they
bisect the opposite angles hmm I can't
remember what you can do and this is a
nice little tip here is go ahead and
make an extreme example okay so there's
a rectangle you can see the four right
angles right but when you draw the
diagonal check this out look at that
diagonal does this angle look like it's
congruent to that angle
not even close right so you can tell you
know that the diagonals are not
bisecting or cutting the opposite angles
in half
but if you draw your rectangle like this
it almost looks like a square and when
you draw that diagonal you'll think oh
yeah it does look like it's bisecting so
that's why I say try to draw like maybe
an extreme example of that particular
shape and you'll be able to get a sense
of whether what you're investigating is
true or not but if you internalize this
tree diagram and understand that the
ones that are below it have the
properties of the one above it you'll be
on your way to memorizing all these
different shapes and their properties so
if you're enjoying these videos
subscribe to the channel I look forward
to having you as a member and we'll talk
about more math videos coming up in the
days and weeks and months ahead and go
ahead and check out some of my past
videos I'll see you in the next video